but
in my opinion they're not going to
detect the dark matter
because it doesn't exist that's my
personal opinion
i'm here with professor john moffatt
part of what i'm doing with this
channel as well as this documentary is
to
place people who i think have gotten
not as much press as they should you've
heard of lee small and you've heard
you've heard of eric weinstein
especially from the intellectual dark
web
you've heard of sabine haasenfelder
because of her youtube channel but not
many people have heard
at least in the public have heard of
john moffitt and he deserves
just as much credit he's put out quite a
few
theories and not many people put out
even one theory they usually develop an
existing theory
so i'm super excited to meet with john
in person
john how are you doing very good thank
you let's hear about your modified
theory of gravity
so um
this non-symmetric theory which i
worked on i decided that the
anti-symmetric part
of this metric tensor
was not the electrolytic field it was
additional degrees of freedom for
gravity
it was part of the gravitational field
okay
and uh so i called it the non-symmetric
gravitational theory
now comes the first acronym ngt
let me just break this down for the
audience quickly so in general
relativity of the two tensor
as i was saying before then you have the
symmetric it's
it's a symmetric tensor but any tensor
can be broken up into symmetric and an
anti-symmetric part you can decompose it
much like you can with coordinates
there's an x and y
or if you know about principal bundles
there's a horizontal vertical part so
you can decompose
so you can decompose and tensor into
symmetric and anti-symmetric part
anti-symmetric part is just zero in the
einstein field equations
typically and what moffett is working on
or
was working on was realizing that this
anti-symmetric part which einstein also
tried to work on
is not doesn't represent
electromagnetism
which is why i signed through it out
because he was trying to make it fit
you're like wait maybe it's not
electromagnetism but it's something else
okay and you can correct me if i'm
incorrect
very good perfect okay um
that's a succinct description
so i published a paper
in physical review 1979
called a new theory of gravitation what
you do is
in theoretical physics is the following
you have an idea
as richard feynman so you guess an
idea now i'm going to discuss
how we would look for a new law in
general we look for new law by the
following process first we guess it
then we com don't let that's really true
and
okay you have this idea it takes seconds
to have the idea okay
but then you have to formulate it in
in terms of a mathematical system
mathematical equations
okay so you do that and you have to be
self-consistent
and then you have to
test it against experiment
and it's three phases and
the latter part the third phase is very
important
because you have to know whether it's
correct or not experimentally
it's physics you're doing physics not
just mathematics
and but if it's not
doesn't fit the data then
you throw away that guess that idea and
you
start with some other idea or you
quit and this is how physics is done
so uh i had tried to find some way of
verifying this non-symmetric gravity too
it's not easy
doing experimental gravity physics is
this is difficult
of course i had to agree with einstein's
theory of gravity
that's the first necessary
thing to find is correct if it doesn't
agree with
it presently solar experimental data for
example
then this the whole thing is off
so uh
also there were some
people criticized it too just you have
to have criticism
physics is a very conservative business
you do not
change the paradigm in physics unless
you absolutely have to
and it's the paradigm shift is usually
driven by experimental physics
some the presence theory so-called
standard theory
by the way i don't like that i won't
stand it but anyway standard theory
doesn't agree with some data or a theory
comes forward that predicts
makes a prediction and
your theory fits the data that
prediction fits but the older theory
doesn't
this is how physics progresses
and uh so also
at this point this was a 1979.
so i worked on this 80s 1980s
i had students working on
and uh for example had neil cornish
graduate student who was from australia
and uh he's now professor
uh university of montana uh
he's found coy senior professor the
head of a gravity gravitational
physics group and um
so we we worked on this and i had a
potential solution for a black hole
which did not have a horizon
okay and uh
using your modifier we're using this
modified theory
a black hole with no horizon that's
right uh cornish
applied for a position at cambridge
university to be a
hawking subsistence stephen hawking's
assistant and he
became his assistant it's quite a funny
story
because uh as neil told me later
he was sitting in one of the rooms of
the
department of applied mathematics the
silver street cambridge where
hawking was and he's
looking at the blackboard at a
blackboard and he suddenly hears this
voice
computer voice ah so you're a neil
cornish
so you don't believe in black holes i
believe
that was his first thing
so uh anyway so uh
so this is the 80s so
i started that then i started doing in
particle physics again and
left it for a while i worked on unified
theory again
with another graduate student david bowe
who ended up as a professor simon fraser
university
british columbia he was chair actually
of the department at one point
david bowen b.o.l and also with gabor
constanta
who became professor and dean of science
at
the university of winnipeg in manitoba
we worked on that stuff and but uh there
was no clear experimental evidence
that could prove it you have to have one
piece of experiment
of some some prediction something that
you have in your theory
that cannot be fitted by other theories
this is very difficult this doesn't
happen often in physics
maximum's prediction that light has to
move as an electrical wave
with the speed of light is a prediction
which uh hurts
parts the physicist brought
experimentally to be correct this is a
remarkable result
the iraq is dirac equation one of the
fundamental equations of
quantum field theory in quantum
mechanics relativistic quantum
physics uh predicted antimatter
but they went and looked for anti-murder
and anderson
car they found in 1932 this is a an
amazing prediction
see so this happens
a few times in physics einstein's
theory of general relativity had to pass
the solar system
experiments and the bending light of
course
1.57 or 5 seconds
bending of light by the sun um
the first eclipse experiments were not
all that great actually
and time had to go on before we had a
really
confirmation of the bending of light
protection
by einstein and uh the perineal advance
of mercury this is the
uh the rosetta procession
of mercury's orbit mercury is the planet
closest to the sun
and it presents in the norwegian shades
on a set of shape
which confounded newtonian gravity
where does your modified theory come in
so i had to fit all this
with my modified theory but then
i got interested in dark matter
because there was beginning to be
interesting
in the 70s very reuben astronomers of
women astronomer and ford
uh colleague did exper
observations of uh rotation curves of
galaxies
if you observe doppler shifts
uh light coming and going blue shifting
richard
and from these observations you can
determine
how fast stars are moving around in the
galaxy
in a galaxy and they found
with great surprise that the stars were
moving faster than
could be accounted for by newtonian
gravity
if you plot the rotation curve
of the speed velocity
vertical axis versus the distance
of the size of the star from the center
are equal to zero
radially then the curve comes up
and flattens out whereas you're touring
gravity predicts that it
should fall off okay and it's quite a
six times
the diff at the difference between the
touring gravity and this flat rotation
curve experimentally
observationally it's it's a factor of
six
and that's confined to a galaxy that's
what happens in our galaxy
and well the reason i'm saying that is
because we're gravitationally pulled by
some other galaxy so
if that curve extended out extremely far
then we should be spinning
you get back to newtonian gravity and
you must go
as you go towards infinity
so it flattens out and then comes back
down again
so this intrigued me because einstein
gravity
contains newtonian gravity and we
effectively use
newtonian gravity for galaxies because
the gravitational field is weak
all experiments
um on gravity are for weak gravitational
fields
the solar system is weak gravity
except for neutron stars
einstein mutant it doesn't work dark
matter
what is this so in the 70s
that the first astronomer to
to note this problem was uh she was
ricky in 1933
swiss astronomer rather century
character he has his name on
virtually every aspect of physics he
did some calculations for what are
called clusters
these are clusters of galaxies not stars
galaxies containing stars and these
clusters are huge
and he found that what's by what's
called the variable theorem
that they if you use newtonian gravity
they can't be stable they have to blow
apart
gravity is not sufficiently strong to
maintain
uh equilibrium stability
so he said well there's got to be extra
better dark matter
and that's it already 1933
and so on but no one paid much attention
to it
but that because of vera ruben and the
problem with the galaxies
now things became serious and uh
more and more attention was paid to
a stock matter and now
it's to me in my opinion one of the
major problems of modern physics
because due to the standard cosmology
which i will get into
the standard cosmological model
dark matter plays an essential role
85-86
of all matter is dark matter
according to fitting the data
cosmological data um
so after decades
of effort and large
sums of money millions billions of
dollars
one experiment after another they've
been looking for dark matter particles
and no one can detect them no one has
detected them
so what does this mean
um it i tend i call it
potentially the modern ether because
ether was
accepted as being a fact
at the end of the 19th century
beginning of the 20th century it was a
fact
because you had to have electromagnetic
waves move
some through some medium like siren
moves through
air as a medium maximum believed in
ether
and so what does your modified theory of
gravity say about dark matter
so i decided to
say that um that they like this
mark of the anti-symmetric part of my
gravity theory
what's the part of gravity
that modifies gravity without
matter you see because the first
modification of gravity
a serious modification was isaac newton
was uh albert einstein who modified
isaac newton's
gravitational theory published in 18
in 1687 in the pricipia
and uh so i'm modifying einstein okay i
mean that's
einstein is failing newtonian and
einstein
are failing they cannot
describe this issue without
inventing invisible matter
but one is always agnostic in physics
if you can find the dark matter
next month these huge experiments
that are still ongoing trying to detect
what's called wimps
massive particles if they find that it
fits in and they can explain the
rotation curves of the galaxies
then forget about modification
einstein's theory gravity is a beautiful
theory
it fits the data and that's it
but in my opinion they're not going to
detect the dark matter
because it doesn't exist that's my
personal opinion
okay so
uh so i published papers
uh doing this identifying this
anti-symmetric part with them
as a new to career freedom and gravity
so that i could fit the galaxy rotation
curves the flattening of the curves
without dark matter and i did okay
and i published a paper in 1995
physics let's be doing this but it was
um astronomers complain because
non-symmetric gravity theory is
complicated and they don't astronomers
don't like this complication
so i said all right i'll produce a
simpler version
so i produce what's called uh
mstg matrixcu symmetry
gravity then your previous version so
taking the previous
version and making it a simpler theory
and when you say it's simpler well it's
it's
what are you sacrificing for the
simplicity i'm sacrificing a lot of the
mathematical mathematics i made it into
a simpler version by means of
throwing out a lot of the complicated
non-linear mathematics
okay so the way that i'm imagining it
is like a taylor expansion you just take
the linear part and just remove that
exactly right okay so then
i've published papers with this on dark
matter i simplified it again
because this drawing work started with
still complaining
so i i'll say okay i'll make it simpler
so now it's
down to scalar tensor vector gravity
stvg
and this consisted of taking einstein's
theory
you've got to have einstein's theory as
a base
otherwise it's not going to work when
you say you have it as a base you mean
you
derive it in a limit like newton's
that's driving exactly
you have to do that einstein was
confounded
by the fact that he couldn't get
newtonian gravity
over a period of a year or two and he
gave up at one point but then he went
back in
with grossmont and and eventually
they go around to getting what's called
the poisson equation
and utorine gravity has a limit natural
limit of ice dichroid
so i had to have this so it's okay
so now i have a theory where
i need a stronger gravity so i made
big g i call it big g newton's constant
i made it a variable constant
interesting and
following what paul directed in 1938
perceives the royal society
in nature about nature article you also
have a variable speed of light
is that tied to the variables that's
another theory okay
so um by the way
the photon of gravity the quantum
the photons in quotes is the graviton
the graviton is is the quantum particle
that
is exchanged between particles
meta particles and produces newtonian
gravity or einstein gravity
okay in electrodynamics maximum's
electroneum is a relativistic version
of microsoft siri the photon is
exchanged between electrons
to produce the coulomb force okay so the
focus graviton is the photon
no one's ever detected a graviton and
probably no one ever will
because gravity is so weak
he would take the whole galaxy as an
accelerator to detect a graviton
as freeman tyson said
if you have a big enough mass to
to uh detect the graviton that mass
would collapse to apply
anyway that's the theory okay the
graviton so
so here i have the metric tensor field
of einstein and then i have a new
degree of frame the vector field
and the vector field corresponds to a
spin one graviton
whereas the metric tensor t mu
corresponds to a
spin two graviton so i complete
gravity with an extra graviton it's been
one graviton
and this vector field is sourced by
matter by mass
okay so the electromagnetic potential
a mu of maxwell's equations is sourced
by electric charge
my vector field is sourced by mass just
like
einstein's metric theory field theory is
field is sourced by monster by density
of matter
so that's affected to the theory and
i wrote it up and uh
published it in 2006
and eventually
i started calling it mog modified
clarity
because this modded modifier
milkroom in israel
he was the first to publish a
modification of newtonian gravity
uh command modifying newtonian dynamics
right in 1983 and he
he's a pioneer i mean to do this because
people were critical i mean you know
modify einstein gravity
so um this is mind
but mine is a non-relativistic
formula it's not relativistic it's just
a modification it's a modification
newtonian gravity
and it's based on assuming there's a
special acceleration
a sub zero a for acceleration
and a 0 a sub 0 it makes it special
as rotation and this is a number list
it's a 1.2 times 10 to the minus
power turns the power minus 10 meters
per second squared
this is a unit of acceleration that's
monde even if mont had correct
predictions it would still be incomplete
because
how does it comport with the general
relativity would be the open question
because people attempted to
generalize this non-relativistic
phrenological formula
a simple formula by the way astronomers
like this simple formula
was it astronomers like the simple
matters
yeah so it's a high school level
formula okay so um
i don't want it's not a sense i mean my
sense of humor is
today i call it marx you sort of mind
them
and ask tvg is
but uh this is silly but um
mark which is important it's called mark
because it's modified gravity
right as opposed to modifying newtonian
dynamics
so you've got to have general role
you've got to have general relativity
okay so the big question everyone wants
to know and the experimentalists who are
watching this is do you make predictions
that agree
with the data okay so back to this
three phases of physics have an
idea guess it mathematical formulation
htvg you publish it
now comes what i call i call it physics
his imagination
in a straight jacket imagination the
idea
the straight jacket is experimental
physics
can you agree with experimental physics
can you predict something
that the other people can't fit
it's hard that's why physics is so hard
because it
when i paint i still
paint um there's no criteria you have to
match
no i you i paint my i don't think it's
all left
it's all right brain more or less about
feelings
color composition so i finish
put it up on the wall and you either
like it or you don't like it
yeah i don't have to prove anything i
don't have to prove the painting
you see it's not physiological i don't
approve it
just if you don't like it well okay
maybe you like this painting but um in
physics
the test is to experiment and this is
what makes physics so hard
it's very challenging that's why i like
it okay
so uh okay moving forward
one paper after another i've been
publishing papers now
for 14 years https tvg was published in
2006.
so then in 2015
published a pair long paper uh
on marked black holes because i found it
by all solution
okay right and i call them marked black
holes i call them
schwarzschild mog fly halls or curb
by hulker my former collaborator and
friend
from trinity and
there's been a lot of i've lost track
how many papers are published on my play
halls
oh okay great because one of my
questions was what's the reception like
from the physics community
i i there must be i don't know i'm
guessing
50 60 papers that's a lot of citations
hundreds of citations in fact
i'm up to something like six thousand
seven
thousand citations holy moly yeah
there's something called research gate
which is a
portal he was wrapped on that so i'm up
to
something at 11 000.
holy moly yeah so
a lot of people know me from my physics
but um uh this paper i just sent you
just
from chinese from china published
yesterday
it's owned on the archive it'll be
published eventually it's a very
very good paper because i published
in my big paper on mark black halls
published the european physical journal
c
and this is a major european journal
in 2016 and subsequent papers
uh i published a a
solution of my modified gravity theory
for an object which may not have
horizons
and is regular it does not have any
singularity at the center
it's completely regular interesting
but it's close to having a horizon
because there's a critical
in in the development there's a free
parameter called alpha
in the mathematics of the the metric
describing my multiply hole
and this alpha is a deviation parameter
it deviates
the theory from einstein black holes
the size of alpha when alpha is zero
you get heights time black holes
when half is not zero you don't okay so
in addition to the
black hole with a horizon actually
my solution mock player always has two
horizons
and the parameters are just mass and
spin
and alpha three parameters that's it
so
i published no charge
mass spin and alpha no charge
no electric charge by the way blind host
astrophysical bodies do not have
electric charge
the electrical neutral because
you have positive charge electrons and
you have positive and negative charge
clumps of charge right
and they neutralize one another i mean
this is
this is electrically neutral all
astrophysical borders are
bodies are electrically neutral the sun
is electrically neutral
there may be a tiny amount of charge but
it's negligible
so it has very little of any effect on
the
on space-time metric
through max einstein equations okay
this is for astrophysics so black holes
should be electrically neutral papers
are published showing
this is the case they neutralize
so they discharge their charge
so this theory is just mass
but mass is positive it doesn't have a
negative counterpart
there's no negative mass so there's no
electric so-called
equivalent of the dipole there's no mass
dipole okay because you can't have a
positive negative mass at two poles
so um anyway so
um by the way if someone is interested
and they have a pension for mathematics
as well as physics
and they want to learn about your theory
do they just read the papers or do you
have a book
that you published much like there are
books that introduce someone to general
relativity from nothing
no i haven't actually published
um a textbook on this i'm too busy
working out the theory
probably i i do these but just i just
dictate them
but doing a textbook is much more
complicated
because you have to deal with all the
questions and this but eventually i hope
to get a review
but um there was a review published by
um daniela perez
and gustav romero
they're at the institute for physics in
argentina
and they published a whole
large big review of what is my mug
in a book what do you think of current
theories of everything
are they missing some key ingredient are
they missing that they're trying to
unify gr as it is
and they're not unifying mog or is there
something else that you feel like
they're lacking
okay well there's a long history to this
we just talked about unified
way back harmony and albert einstein
1918 but um
um yeah it's it's i don't
i think there's a loop there's m theory
i'm happy with this
this um toe
the acronym tone yeah what does it mean
to have a theory of everything
i mean what everything i mean the whole
university
biochemistry chemistry consciousness
i don't know what does it mean to have a
theory every i don't understand what
that means
so you much prefer grand unified theory
than tolkie that's grand unified theory
oh grand unified theory somehow
tied in with gravity
have you had a chance to look at the
eric weinstein video that i sent you
yeah i didn't understand it i don't um
you have to ask him about that what
about stephen wolfram have you heard of
steven
uh
i appreciate that they they both made a
lot of money
i apparently eric einstein is
manager of a ph fund and netron fund in
new york
so he's always a mathematician
so he has has fun with it
right um but um
these theories have not been successful
quantum gravity let's talk about that
for a minute i've
because i publish papers in corn and
crevice i try to probably in all of
these things
and so several papers actually over the
years
quite quite well cited actually i
published one paper in 2000
called non-commutative content gravity
which has many
citations so you have the coordinates of
space time not commuting
by momentum and precision
between quantum mechanics
non-communicative
non-communicative gravity moffat okay
the problem
with point of gravity is that there are
no data
okay let me repeat that there are no
quantum gravity data
and you can't do physics without data
that is my main criticism
there may be i mean i'm not saying there
won't be
but as of august 2020
there i know let's put it this way
the quantum field theory the feynman
graphs
describe what's going on relativistic
quantum field theory
so you have what's called tree graphs
these are trees okay so you have a line
here
and you have a line there these are two
electrons and they
just interchange the photon which is a
quickly line
and it's just trees but that's classical
electromagnetism is classical
electrodynamics
tree graphs so the quantum
comes in with what's called loose
so now you begin to take the lines and
and make them into loops
close in on loops okay
and these loops are the quantum
corrections to the
classical tree graphs okay
so let's go to gravity gravity you have
you have a neutron two neutrons or
two electrons and they have mass
so the mass uh causes the graviton to be
interchanged
between the two massive electrons of
protons whatever and
that's classical i can then derive from
that tree graph
graviton and two protons
i can derive newtonian's law of gravity
one of r squared law
dealing with getting general activities
of different business
and the loops quantum gravity comes in
when i form these loops which are
proportional to
planck's constant now now price constant
comes in
to the game and these are called self
energy
loops so yeah they're loop crafts and
there's no experiment that can determine
these loop graphs
none this is where the quantum gravity
comes in
so you construct the theory of gravity
uh quantum gravity you know there are
lots of
there's loop quantum gravity where you
um take space time and make it into
little pieces atomic pieces lattices
and uh you then try to get
general relativity coming up emerging
out of this
spin that work and all that there's a
string theory where you have these
strings
like violin strings and one of the
strings is i spent two graviton
so i did these strings awesomely
and the strings are not points in space
time
so your issue is that they're theorizing
with no constraints because there's not
much data
yeah so strength there has to be
formulated in 10 dimensions
or 11. otherwise it's not
self-consistent
and you have to have supersymmetry
suppressivity has to come in otherwise
it's not self-consistent
physically speaking what's the
difference between being self-consistent
and being consistent
well for example you need more
dimensions
and strength theory otherwise the lorenz
algebra doesn't close
it's not lawrence invarian
um it's because the string is a a
surface it's not a point and
so then i worked in string theory i once
gave a
course of summer lectures at the
university of western ontario
in london but for students and i
published it actually
and that turned me off straight theory
in fact
the claim is the string theory is finite
to all orders of
perturbation theory so you take my three
grams from my loops
and you do what's called perturbation
theory the loops have perturbations
on the string on the tree graphs and the
strength area these
loops are supposed to be finite whereas
in
standard quantum electronegative quantum
field 3
they lead to divergences so you have to
renormalize
the loops you know you have to take one
infinity and subtract it from another to
get a finite result
so um
so these two gravities by the way
gravity is not only normalizable
this was proved by tuft and development
and others in the 70s and this was a big
problem
and so it doesn't behave like an other
standard quantum field theories and
particle physics
and uh so it's not running all my
divergences you can't get rid of them
so this is what loop current gravity's
supposed to deal with
and strength theory is supposed to be
finite but i discovered that
i wasn't convinced that the string
theory is finite
i'm not there was never any rigorous
proof that street theory is finite still
yeah and so let's get to the phase three
what about testing these theories
well string theories was a theory of
everything's
supposedly a toe okay that's where the
acronym came from
and uh um
it would written and so forth uh
and the eighties claimed that this is
the the theory okay of everything
everything in particle and physics
so
well no one's ever detected a higher
dimension
beyond three spatial dimensions
time is a dimension but this there's
just space-time
clocks versus rods and uh
okay so we never seen our identification
the large hadron collider has looked for
them
for years and not find nothing no
experimental data
okay supersymmetry we need supersymmetry
to make the fermion sector
or string theory consistent there are
reasons why
say consistent but let's go on um
so they've tested they've
content for super symmetry for years
here we see
we know supersanity doesn't exist
up to about three tv three or four tv
and so it's got to exist below
one tv to really solve a lot of super
symmetric problems
so that's all gone okay there's no
evidence for super symmetry
so the light agent collider is at 14 tv
uh well it's been working at 13 14 13 ta
and they hope to get it up to 14 tv with
i'm even beyond that but you know it's a
super symmetric particles keep getting
heavier and heavier and we can't detect
them
so that's gone so what's left of string
theory okay
there's no experimental test of string
theory
that you can say well this experiment's
done
and it passes this test and no other
theory
no there without supersymmetry can fit
that data
doesn't exist you modified gravity have
you worked on modifying qft
okay so another i
the standard model what i why i
formulate alternatives is not because
i'm trying to be a difficult person
i'm just curious about how
stable how um true
as the so-called standard model is how
robust is it
okay so that's why i and also i'm
mentally somewhat lazy i i can't just
sit and read
someone's textbook so in order to learn
a theory i i produce another theory
and through this i can't produce another
theory unless i really understand
the so-called standard model theory and
that makes me forces me to understand it
so this is a strange mental way of
proceeding but that's that's why
that's why all these alternatives come
out because i went trying to understand
the standard model
by producing another one and
uh so the other model is also strong
strong man woman so to speak you know i
can knock it down or
make it look true so the way that i
analogize it is that it would be
if as if someone can't watch movies or
can't understand movies so they're like
let me make my own movie
and then i gotta watch this movie and
understand how this director made it in
order for me to make mine and that's my
actual goal is to understand this
director yes that's right exactly
so uh yeah so super saiyan which is
it's uh the so then yeah so then
i got interested in the fact of the
normalization theory so
i mean i published papers on on particle
physics
from the after doing my phd
so i've been doing this for years i have
phd students working on just on particle
physics
quark physics and everything lots of i
had 38
graduate students by the way who did
phds
that's quite a lot so
um so i
i was interested in the following can
you develop
a theory which is ultra out of
ultraviolet complete uv complete
in other words in standard core and
future these loops i was talking
about they have divergences they're
called ultra divided
ultraviolet divergences and they have to
be cancelled using
renormalization theory so you do what's
called
charge and mastery normalization and uh
iraq never liked renormalization theory
he thought it was
it was unsatisfactory it's rather
artificial
you take one set of infinities and it
subtracts from another
you know why do you have these
infinities in the first place
the final fireman and that in the 80s he
was interviewed he
said he he wasn't satisfied with
normalization theory
even though he was one of the inventors
with his uh nobel prize in coronary
dynamics
and um so i constructed a different
quantum field theory
and i use what's so instead of having
in in these graphs you have
two graphs two lines or three lines
meeting at a point it's called a vertex
okay and that's that's where these three
particles
interact at the point so in local corner
field theory
they interact at a point
and this point is effectively described
by delta function
that i invented by the iraq by the way
who didn't like renormalization
and as i as feynman already understood
in his
paper from 1947 1950
this already there you already have a
problem as soon as you introduce
the delta function and the point
uh for the vitamin graphs
you get it you get subversions
immediately
so cell to function in mathematics is
what's called a distribution
you know you get into distribution
theory so i thought well
uh i'm going to give a different
distribution at a point
so i use western called an entire
function
entire function mathematics entire
function
time function is a digit for
distribution has an infinite number of
derivatives
uh it has in the in the complex
momentum square plane there are no waves
there are no poles but there's a
essential singularity of infinity
that's the only singularity so it's an
infinite
taylor series of derivative taylor
series of derivatives
so it's infinite derivative theory okay
and so i it becomes non-local
the operators become non-local so i have
a non-local field theory
but i stress that i've published this
that i
proved that even though the operator
field operators are non-local
the theory does not violate micro
causality
micro causality is where the micro micro
causality is the
commutator of um
to f of a field at two different points
and it's supposed to vanish with space
like separation outside the light column
and i proved that this is even though
the field operators are non-local
they still have these vanishing
commutators outside they like cold
so the theory is local it's local even
though it's
called non-local the actual result in
the end is local
that's interesting so i published a
paper in 1989
physical review long paper
during this and uh what's the reception
from
proved that it was finite to all others
it was you did true to all orders
what's the reception been like okay so
richard wounded
i got to know him he's professor
university of
florida at gainesville uh
this was 1990. so he came up to toronto
to give some lectures i invited him up
he said what are you doing i said
non-local phil theory
what he said well that can't work
i said well i'm publishing this paper
so so uh six weeks later
in comes uh an email we were already
emailing them
saying i've had epiphany epiphany
i think this is really interesting let's
collaborate
so we collaborated with myself and his
student and my student
my postdoc and
we published a long paper and physical
review
where we did coin related dynamics from
start to finish
everything and proved that the theory is
unitary to all this is s matrix
its units of orders all the perturbation
loops of
finite orders and the three graphs work
and so we really want to turn on this
so that papers had many citations okay
uh so people are publishing beyond it
just the other day with paper camera
they're coming out
exciting my papers
i've had hundreds of citations on this
so um i got back into this recently
because i switched i thought i'd be
being done enough
black holes and gravity let's do some
particle physics for a change
so i look back into the standard model
and his particle has been discovered the
discovery of the higgs particles
is the narrative for that is in my
pocket
cracking the particle court of the
universe or
oxford university press no
collins harper collins this is yeah yeah
so um so there
the standard model so what you do is you
have
the strong nuclear force is called
quantum chromodynamics
and you have quarks all the clocks
and they the the photon in this case the
quantum is the
gluon and the colon is colored and when
you say quote photon in quotations you
mean the
particle that mediates the force it's
the medium
of the force the medium of the force
the mediator of the force and then you
have uh
electromagnetism electrophotomics qet
is called and you have electoral week
and these are put together were put
together by
glashow and
basically as su 3 consists u2 cross u1
issue 3 is the color nuclear force
strong force group issue 2
is the um hu2 core g1 is the
electro electro weak and the u1 is the
electromagnetism so these are the three
forces of niche
protocol and this it's called simple
group
and um why is it an issue sequence
issued to
q1 so
so how do they do this okay well in
order to get a
renormalizable theory we use a delta
function
for the tre the craft firemancrafts at
the point
local field theory um
you um you need a gauge theory
that there has to be gauging variant
and corner electronics is gazing variant
because the photon is massless
so massive theories are gauging grain
and changing veins theories are
normalizable
okay
now the quantum chromodynamics hu3 the
gluons are massless
hooray we have a cage theory all right
and it's it's really normalizable it's
called qct
quantum chromodynamics what about the
weak force so there's always been a
problem so the weak force
with these forces are described by
fields are described by
yangno's theory a young male says what's
called a mathematics or non-opinion
gate theory it's gauge theory
the particle mediating particles are
meshless
okay so for a long time
the the problem was that that
like the electric weak is not matchless
because the mediating particles of that
the z with the z
posing on and the w botons there are
three of them
two w charge and one neutral that's it
they're not massless five they have fake
masses
and the fermions are not massless the
electrons and quartz the top cork
is uh the heaviest caulk is 173
tvs compared to the electron which has a
massive or half a
mev so
okay so ask you two cause you were on
one is not engaging you're in
so it can't be renormalized
you can prove this what to do
this took a long time
so the
scalar field was invented the higgs
field
which had to call the numbers of the
vacuum
so uh what they had to do was to say
that the electro weak starts with zero
mass so we put all the masses to zero
that w the z and the photons
zero mass
okay well you know 173 tv is put to zero
okay
and so yeah
w mass is that mass was 92
or so zero okay well
everything is fine so then what they
said was that the higgs field
it's a so-called higgs mechanism
breaks su 2 across u1 turning to u1
so you break the electroweak down to the
electromagnetic
and during this process
the hex field produces the masses
magic okay so
great now that's usually normalizable so
this
hex field has what's called a potential
potential
v of phi fi is a x field
and it's equal to v of phi equals lambda
phi to the fourth
or five to four fourth power of the
scalar
hex field
assume that if you assume that then you
can
get what's called hex mechanism it's the
breaking of the hex symmetry su 2 cross
u1
okay which is supposed to produce the
masses
you keep drawing this because the
mexican hat or this is referring to
something else
that's right so
uh this is all done at the classical
level
the hex mechanism not the quantum level
it's classical but then there's
something called the yukawa
lagrangian like look look you cowardly
chronician
where you have coupling of massive
particles with the higgs field
you multiply them together to interact
and uh for example the electron field
multiplies the spinner electron direct
field
multiplies the hex scalar field stuff
and they have a
coupling constant g g sub b
for an electron so
where did the masses come from
well it turns out that the
cemetery breaking can sort of produce
the tubby in the z-mass
you can get a prediction for the w in
the z mass which looks
well looks reasonably good
but the fermion masses so all the quarks
and
lactones and so on they had to be put in
by hand
and each mass has a coupling constant
and this will call your car on the
ground
we should just fit it by hand so you
never
calculate the masses it's put in by hand
as a free parameter that's why the style
model has
something like 21 or 26 free parameters
depending on how you count
so lots of parameters so
i looked at this and i thought okay well
let me do my
finite quantum field theory as i call it
and it works whether you have masses or
not
because it's not it has a
renormalization but it's a finite
granular
there are no infinities so i don't have
to worry about putting the master to
zero
so i rewrote the standard model assuming
that the masses are not zero that the
symmetry is what it is uh she's three
question two because you want
it's not broken unless you two cause you
want it's not broken and when you came
up with this this was before the higgs
was
discovered yeah well i did that i was
doing this before the eggs
but then my the hex was found i had to
put this in
as as a particle field which i did
and by the way you need the hex field
still
i don't need it for renormalization
and and i don't need it for producing
the message
okay but you do need it because without
the higgs
exchange between two
you violate what's called unitarity at a
participation level
already at about 600
gv this is bad so then when you put in
the higgs field
and to redo the calculation it cancels
all the unitary violations so this means
you get unit you have to have unit
turret
probability has to be conserved so you
still need the eggs okay
so i rated the whole thing and made
everything finite
work did all the calculations prove that
i get all the low energy experiments of
the hatron
collider and um
and now comes the problem
how do i calculate the masses no one's
ever been able to do it
the family analysis so i work on this
occasionally
and i have a way of doing it so stephen
weinberg who
went on the belt price for
the uh initiating this idea of the higgs
mechanism and putting all masses to zero
for leptons
it's called the lepton model other type
he has recently published a paper
trying to solve the problem of the
masses
and steven i was very clever by the way
i mean weinberg's still alive
yes he's by my age
and uh he's i think he's brilliant
huh so but he failed to do it
by his own admission yeah was he using
your modified
quantum field theory no he just doing
the standard
so another criticism is
there's no experimental data that shows
that this pig's potential is lambda
which is the company constant lambda
times phi to the fourth because in order
to
to do the experimental verification you
need
a hex decaying into two other hexes
or three and this the aperture
for this decay product is the
tiniest so there's no evidence for this
potential
that's the standard tail that i've heard
and that everyone has heard yeah it is
the i statement is the the clocks and
the electrons move
through this higgs field vacuum
molasses and they're moving very slowly
and the heavier particles move and the
molasses slower than the
faster ones this is all
okay i mean it's a hypothesis ethereum
i don't necessarily believe in it
imagine this case this is like
completely hypothetical but imagine we
see two electrons and they repel
now we see them but we see them without
photon we didn't discover the photon
then later we discover the photon
and then we say oh okay that makes sense
because we thought that there must be a
mediator
an exchange particle between these two
but we've never seen them exchange
so it would be like that we see the
photon we think they're supposed to be a
particle and that's why we predicted the
photon but you're saying we just found
the
photon in this case the higgs but we
don't see its
mechanism in the way that you're saying
the mechanism exists
we just see the hicks and the hicks can
be explained alternatively
via your theory at least right the point
is that
all experiments with hex particles
the all you ever do experimentally is to
look at
the what's called the decay products
because these particles are so
short-lived they only live 10 to the
power minus 20
10 to the minus 22 10 to the minus 23
seconds
so you can scatter the higgs off one
another
like you scatter off electrons electrons
are stable particles
and protons are stable you can scatter
them
but these things so what you do is
discard it
you you do experiments on the decay
products
how does this heavy particle decay into
the
others and so on and from that you
extract
the electro weak physics
so narrow time i published papers
um where i'm just way back after some
years ago
mexican hat and but now we're
violating special relative lawrence
invariants okay
and so we violated so three color one
down to it so
two and um
so the mexican hat as you remember you
go around the rim
i use different arrows so i choose
to break the arrow in the direction of
time for
cosmology
and so i start with a very low entropy
and the age of three increases as the
universe expands
that's the explanation for the error of
time
should we write through violation of
lorenz ingredients
but this happens fractions of seconds
after the big bang
okay the violation or inconvenience
in experiment experiments today is it's
forget it there is no for me the
violation
occurs seconds or fractions practice the
seconds after the
big bang and then it immediate through a
phase transition
goes directly to the speed of light that
we know measure today
that's important and whereas in
in if you're violating or instant
variance
the way pakistan did with milgram's
external relativistic extensions
you get into trouble and uh
incidentally there
i have met firemen here if i hadn't
dinner with him
in hungary once at a conference he and
his interesting story he was great
um i went to one of his lectures at
caltech
and he was he gave lectures on quantum
field theory
and i sat in the audience and um
he was lecturing away and i put my hand
up just crashed my head
and he looked at me yes do you have a
question
i said i'm just scratching my hand he
said well that's legitimate
you don't like to do that he had a great
sense of humor
i also met young man of course i knew
gilman quite well
murray gilman it's in my this
so funny stories anecdotes
by the way i wanted to check the
following
that when you modify gravity today
okay and you think you can do without
dark matter
or dark energy or explain dark energy
that's another
dark issue you have to fit
all the data you can't
cherry pick the data so mon
does okay for galaxies it doesn't do
well for clusters
this is well known okay so i have to fit
mark has to fit
galaxy data it has to fit what's called
the lensing data
i just published a paper on that another
one so
it has to fit all the cosmological data
it's it's a huge
amount of data so life has become very
difficult
for those people who think they can
modify gravity
okay is you have to fit all the data
otherwise someone comes along and says
hey okay you fit the galaxies
well you fitted that but what about the
cosmology
what about the do you fit the acoustical
power spectrum
at this cosmic microwave background do
you fit the amount of power spectrum
that's the uh spectrum for
statistical analysis of pairs of
galaxies
and to fit the structure growth of
cosmology
so all of this has to be fitted
so i had to learn all of this
you have to do all the astronomy and you
have to do
all the cosmology solar system there
everything has to be fitted
and so far mortgages is
successful there are issues
to do with what's called to off galaxies
by the way it was just a big review
put out by ivante martino
uh published in a journal
uh just recently where he reviews my
mark
he reviews mind and mog
as the two leading theories of
gravity without dark matter okay and
the galaxy fits are very good and so on
anyway
class to fit some data cosmology
but uh there's something called dwarf
galaxies
it's very wrong with torque actually
it's in our galaxy
these are tiny galaxies and
they have what's called very large mesh
to light ratios
and over hell which are
huge so the idea is that the dark matter
dominates them
but um the problem is that they're
probably not
realized some of these 12 calories that
are not stable
tidal deformation destroys the stability
realization and so you can't use them as
data so i mean
so that's how i got
so what are you working on these days uh
well let's see
i've been working on my modified gravity
which i call
the acronym is mug which stands for
modified gravity
but privately modified morphic gravity
but
nothing gravity but that's not public
this private
yes and um the the
various issues i've been developing
uh generalizations of einstein's gravity
theory
already had the phd level
in cambridge attorney college cambridge
and uh over the years but i've worked on
many other subjects
um yes so
developing this theory i also work on
quantum field theory and particle
physics
and cosmology and those are my three
main
areas why don't you tell the audience a
bit about your books
yeah so this is my latest book
uh the shadow of the black hole
oxford university press publication just
came out
it's a history of the gravitational
waves their detection by
ligo observatory
and the history of
black holes and uh
so the book has a narrative
uh description of uh ligo detection of
gravitational waves
and uh also the uh
observation of the first image of a
black hole
in the galaxy m 80s m31
and uh so that's
the book um i also
published a memoir einstein wrote back
some years ago and uh
this is my first book reinventing
gravity which has
a history of privacy starting from
prehistoric times and through the greeks
and
the history of how gravity developed
through
isaac newton and albert einstein
and uh
and then this is the book before
my latest uh cracking the
particle code of the universe is the
history of uh
particle physics and uh
the uh ramifications of a quantum field
theory
and that development and not had the
description of the large hatred and
collider
and all its findings over the years
when you were mentioning the
schwarzschild radius and the equations
you said that it's dependent on the
choice of coordinates the singularity
can you explain to the audience because
to them they might think
well what do you mean dependent on a
choice of coordinate system first of all
what the heck is a coordinate system
and why does the singularity depend on
that yes well the original
solution the slideshow solution
published by schwarzschild
who was astronomer and
by the way he did the work in the
trenches of the first world war he was
in the military
german military in the artillery
and einstein thought that his equation
was so complex that
finding an exact solution would be near
impossible and then one year later
schwarzschild while in the trenches came
up with the solution actually
went back to berlin and brought it up
there
but then he developed an autoimmune
disease
in immune disease which
killed him he died not soon after
publishing the paper
so yeah so they
in the original mathematical solution
uh the one uses what's called schweitzel
coordinates
chord is x y said three dimensional
and time is the fourth dimension so that
produces space time
and you can choose other coordinates
for example if you
do a picture of the
the earth the planet you can use polar
coordinates or
other kinds of coordinates to determine
the uh
the uh structure of the of earth so if
you use polar corners you get a
singularity
on the north and south pole and
similarly in the schwarzschild solution
the the horizon the schweitzer radius
is singular in short show corners but
you choose
other coordinates for example
it was the mathematicians from princeton
published
a paper where they did what's called a
little continuation
of the social corners space
to a much bigger space
in which the the
actual membrane of the horizon was not
singular
so so this was a problem because
uh einstein did wasn't aware of this
issue of courtness
and uh he
people didn't believe in the black holes
because it was singular
einstein didn't like singularities in
his theory he always tried to avoid them
and uh this prevented them
this issue of the singular surface
horizon prevented them from
from believing in these black holes
um but eventually that was cleared up in
the early 60s
and uh so then
from that understanding of not having a
singular membrane surface horizon
surface
someone could begin to believe that
these black holes
made mathematical sense and by the way
there's another singularity
for the black hole when a star
collapses because it has a large mass
too massive to sustain itself
it collapses because the pressure
due to uh what's called degenerate gas
neutron gas for example a neutron
particle gas uh the pressure there is
not big enough to balance
due to the attraction of gravity so the
star collapses
and it collapses in einstein's classical
theory
to a singularity at the center at the
coordinate center which is
radially the distance radially
is zero at the center and this
singularity
has both bothered physicists
uh from the beginning and this year and
uh this this is an issue which i can get
to eventually
so these are the two possible singulars
the singular singularities
at the center and einstein's classical
theory is there
you can't avoid avoid it by choosing
another coordinate system
it's called essential singularity
whereas
as i explained for the horizon you can
choose different coordinates
and not have a singular surface so the
coordinate
singularities are more like figments of
your coordinate choice
and the essential singularity is one
that is truer
that's right it's always there and the
classical theory of gravity einstein's
theory
you started studying physics around the
time you were 16 you had a
correspondence with einstein directly
20. when you were 20 you had the
correspondence with einstein
and then you started developing your own
theory an extension of general
relativity
okay well i've come i had an unusual
background
um i left school when i was 15
because i wanted to be an artist what
kind of artist
i paint i still paint um
an abstract painting so i joined uh
i went to paris when i was 17.
just turned 17 and uh
i had learned about a size polyakov
abstract painter who has exhibited
paintings in copenhagen
uh before i left for paris and i was
very impressed with his
work so i looked him up he lived an
autism
and how do you look him up this is
before the internet
well i looked him up in the sense of
not the internet i went to his house
because
he had a little apartment and he lived
there with his wife
um madame pollock he just showed up at
his house
a 17 year old kid 17 year old kid and he
had his little boy alex
by their cup and that's where he painted
this room and
he played the guitar at night because he
wasn't more
well-known at all then he became famous
and uh i was there with him for for
about a year
to show up at his house he stayed for a
year no no i i had a room
and porter leon outside near in the
suburbs of paris
just one room but uh
i had saved up some money to to be in
paris
but the money was running out and i
couldn't find
any employment because i was british
danish
i was a british citizen and because of
my father
and so i
painted so he one day he said bring some
paintings along
to the studio and uh we're going to
show you in a show at the at the
museum with your dartmouth
avenue in paris so all of a sudden i
have
four paintings up four or five and this
big
museum modern art museum
and uh i was surrounded by
these abstract painters vasareli
modiyani
polyakov who are now famous names
they're not so you were there before it
was cool before it was famous
before it was santa i was uh
interviewed by by um
journalists from the mall
and other figaro because i was
seventeen very young
to be exhibited at such a famous
installation at the exhibition was
called reality novella
actually it was a spring exhibition
every spring in paris
so i got to know these famous artists
and uh
uh i was with them for a year
and uh then i ran out of money
i had to go back to power to copenhagen
and uh
go back living with my parents again
small apartment
uh and um
i got interested in i started reading
voraciously
everything classics are you a quick
reader
no i'm slowly
i absorb everything carefully
that tends to be true of mathematicians
it turns out that if you
study iq and iq can fractionate into
mathematical and verbal iq
that verbal iq is inversely proportional
to mathematical
so the more highly gifted you are
mathematically the less you are verbally
and then the reverse tends to be true i
must say that school i was not a very
good student
i was you know
i was didn't i the only example i did
well in was chemistry
for some reason i was fascinated by
chemistry
physics no if i was poor physics and
maths
you didn't care too much about it i
didn't care about it i didn't find it
interesting and this is around 15
uh no this is our own 10 11
okay 12 10 yeah we were living in
glasgow at the time what year is this
uh this would be 1942-43 so this is
during the war
do you know anyway uh
so when actually when i left school and
come hang
i did try to get into university and uh
i went uh in those days in copenhagen
you uh went to what's called gymnasium
more like it's something like the
all-german system
educational system and then you
went into the university so i was
interviewed by this
teacher school teacher to see why i
should be admitted
admitted to the gymnasium which is the
portal for university and
uh he asked me that i i should say by
the way that
um during the war
in brisbane bristol this was 1942 in the
battle of britain
july august 1940 uh there were
bombings day and night and uh
i did schooling on the crown way
underground
with sandbags it was terrible
and the teaching was really quite not
very good
and anyway so we went on a vacation to
western supermare a little seaside
resort
coast of england we were walking along
the beach road
promenade and suddenly these two vicious
bombers came up okay bye i looked out i
could see the
pilots and the plane planes and they
dropped six bombs
and uh they fell on the beach which is
why
this is to that tennis court down there
and uh
that's not too far not too far so they
went into the sand which
somewhat muffled to blast but we were
blown across the street
so i i suffer from ptsd
i still do actually to some extent
and uh did you suffer any physical
injuries yeah
suffered a concussion so
this had an effect on me back to the
interview by the school teacher
and flashing back and forward right he
asked me these
questions at the blackboard mathematics
and because of my what we now call
ptsd post somali stress disorder
i just froze i couldn't i froze
and uh i couldn't answer any questions
so he said
he said i can tell you moffitt
actually sure you'll never become a
mathematician
and they rejected me i was rejected
from going to the gymnasium that was the
end of the possibility of attending
university
in denmark so anyway back to uh
so yeah paris copenhagen again
i got interested in and i did a lot of
reading so i read arthur eddington's
books
popular books i got very interested in
that
in the end of physics and astronomy and
uh i started getting excited about that
so i decided this was something to
pursue
so i started learning math and physics
so it turned out that i could attend
the library university live in the
university library
uh like university copenhagen library
and get books from physics and mass
which is
unusual for cities you can't do that in
the university of toronto
the robust library you have to be a
member of the university
so back then any member of the public
could take out the universities
and so i took out these books of maths
and physics
so then i just
it just suddenly clicked
and within about a week or two i learned
calculus
trigonometry uh within
so you found that you had a natural
aptitude that had a nurture happy too
did you find some trick i don't know i i
have to
tell you i never understood how i did
this
to this day you know i still don't
understand it
and within
a couple of months i was moving fast
okay
i was going through all our mathematics
and physics and uh
you must have some great books too yeah
i had i
somehow understood as i moved forward
uh what to look for what books to look
for
and um so within six months
i got up to general relativity and
then i did general relativity within a
month
okay for people listening you went from
a teacher saying that you're never going
to learn mathematics
to you also not knowing much of
mathematics at that time to then you
picking up your first book
in the library for whatever reason you
were curious about it to then learning
general relativity
in the span of six months when you were
around 15 or so
no 19 20 20.
yeah um after that i had no interest in
uh
in science in general but uh
but then i signed in something lit up
and uh so
i then i went on to einstein unified
field theory
and uh studied that and found a problem
with it
when you say einstein's unified field
theory you're not referring to
general relativity no this is uh what he
called a non-symmetric theory
of gravitation he called a
generalization of gravitation to
he didn't call it unified field theory
generalization of gravity uh okay
because this was around the time when
einstein was publishing
people like for example me we don't know
much about what einstein published that
didn't work we were only taught what
worked which is gr
and the special relativity first so i
don't i actually don't know about
the specifics of his unified field
theory attempts yeah
now he when he
this is a lot of this is described in my
book reinventing gravity
i go through the whole history of this
um
after the 1915-16 publication of general
relativity
einstein kept publishing applications
like detection of gravitational waves
his famous book on the cosmology and so
on his famous
article in cosmology but he
was more interested in unifying
electromagnetism with gravity
and making the one geometrical theory
okay
and that he started this in uh
about 19 18 19 19.
isn't general relativity already
compatible with electromagnetism
it was because you can incorporate
maxwell's equations of electromagnetism
into general relativity in what's called
a covariant way
a way of of not being dependent on any
particular coordinate system
it's called the einstein maxwell theory
and it
is but maxwell's equations are not
unified with gravity
so to speak in a geometrical structure
ah
okay so
he worked on and off on the unified
theories
his generalization of gravitational
theory his theory
and in 1925 he for example
he followed collusion and worked on
high dimensional gravity to include the
electromagnetic field
at maxwell's equations and he wasn't
happy with that
and then he vile
herman weil the famous german
mathematician
who published a book famous book on
einstein's theory gravity called mata
and space time space time and meta
he developed a unified theory called the
while unified field theory and
this was actually the beginnings of
what's called gage theory
in quantum field theory quantum physics
but that failed because
einstein criticized that there was a
problem with
uh understanding how clocks work in the
theory because of this so-called case
theory
and but then in 1925 einstein
uh journalized his correct general
relativity theory
by saying the following generality
is based on a space-time metric
which is as it's what it says a
symmetric
metric it's a symmetric tensor
okay g mu u it's called
where mu and you run over space-time
coordinates one to four
and
so he said well why should this metric
this
tends to be symmetric it can be
non-symmetric you have a symmetric plus
an antisymmetric part
added together just let me explain this
a bit to the audience
so there's a metric which is a two
tensor and a tensor
is what you can think of as taking two
vectors you know what a vector is
and then outputting what your underlying
field is which in
most of the cases it's the real numbers
so that is you eat two vectors
give me two vectors and i'll give you a
real number and you have to satisfy some
conditions like
linearity and so on you can also switch
those two vectors so you can say give me
a vector a
give me one vector then give me another
one or give me that one
and then give me the other one so give
me a and b or give me b and a and then
if the result is the same in your
calculation then
you call it symmetric okay that's right
so yeah so um anyway he developed the
mathematics for this and
published it as a paper in 1925 there
was a lot of excitement about
any publication that he produced because
1925 was famous but
depending on my
verified general relativity in 1919
arthur eddington's uh
expedition uh to to africa
and uh solar eclipse and so on
and uh anyway so the anyway so
back to the non-symmetric theory then he
left it
and tried other made other attempts to
have a unified theory
he felt they failed
so uh 1945
uh in collaboration with strauss
he was einstein's assistant at the
institute for one study in princeton
where he now is okay 1945
professor then in institute um
he went back to the non-symmetric
theory and
worked with ios droughts but there was a
problem
because the field equations of the
theory
are attracted beautiful looking
it's quite natural to generalize
einstein's theory
there's no reason why this tensor should
be symmetric
and some what's called the connection
uh to which is associated with the
metric tensor
at the ifine connection is also
non-symmetric
in this theory and it has a symmetric
power which is the iphone connection
which is not a tensor and the skew
anti-symmetric part
the skew part which is is a tensor
anyway
so uh it turned out that the
field equations which are supposed to
describe maxwell's
equations were not maxwell's equations
and he couldn't get the equation of
motion for a charged particle
it was called the the lawrence lawrence
force law
hendrick lawrence the physicist
developed this
the turn of the uh 20th century
um the lorentz force on on the charged
particle
didn't come out of the theory pretty bad
serious so
people criticized this sorry
publications
and uh so i looked at his theory
and i found another problem with it uh
so he did at that time he had what's
called an emission
metric tensor so he had the symmetric
power was real
and the antisymmetric power was it was
an imaginary
quantity measure square root of minus
one times
the imaginary part and i found the
problem with the
the lagrangian what's called the action
principle from which you get the field
equations
so i wrote him a letter and i wrote two
papers actually
but that is to say you found a problem
with the lagrangian or the action that
he yeah
the the structure of the action as to
whether it was real or not
the action that lagrange has to be real
okay
otherwise you get into trouble with uh
uh the development of the theories look
self-consistent
so i wrote these two papers i
typed on an old typewriter and uh
with the math symbols on the old
typewriter too no i had to
remember by a pen it's all very
primitive
compared to what we do today and uh
sent him these manuscripts and the
letter i never expected to hear from him
because i mean famous einstein like
people were writing to him all the time
be like writing obama and then obama
replying to
exactly so however my prison was
was correct so 20 or 22 or
20 92 i was 20 are you
and
so he right looked at the manuscript and
hmm okay so you corrected einstein
yeah so i'm not correct i'm i questioned
what he was doing
and uh so he amazingly and
um a letter comes in from
from princeton from mercer street where
he
had his house and uh
discussing my paper papers and
and uh discussing this issue i raised
and so on
so we got into a correspondence and so
this went on
for some months and uh i also criticized
the fact that he was only
unifying gravity with electromagnetism
and that we knew about the nuclear force
i mean there was it was already nuclear
what we call nuclear physics
so how can you leave that out okay and
he
responded to that so
then um
we have we had a friend my father
had a friend who was a chemist
and uh living he called me an american
and uh he got to hear about me
and uh then he
somehow got that nils boy at the morning
teacher
got to hear about me and i was invited
to the poor institute and i was
interviewed by niels paul
for two hours he criticized einstein
because
people felt einstein was wasting his
time
moore criticized einstein yeah and said
that uh
albert was wasting his time and he
he said i was like an alchemist
trying to turn lead into gold and so on
and so on
i just sat there famous
nobel prize winner thinks another famous
nobel prize winner is wasting his time
okay i didn't think einstein was wasting
his time
he was doing unified theory before it
ever became popular
at all okay and he was actually ignored
at institute
by physicists because
all of his work was just wasting time
so uh support
i was a british citizen you see because
i never became a danish citizen because
i was born in copenhagen but i took my
father's citizenship
so paul got in touch with uh
the uh consulate but he's consciously in
copenhagen
i have got in touch with the department
of scientific industrial association
in london and they invited me to london
and uh so i went there
but uh they arranged
me for me to be interviewed by
professors
to see whether i was the real article or
some figment or somebody's imagination
including my own and uh
i was interviewed by william mcrae
professor in london university
and uh
then i was sent to uh william bono who
professor liverpool university who was
working
on united states unified field theory he
was one of the people who criticized
einstein's theory for the fact that you
could get the equation of motion for a
charged particle
from the theory and also that maxwell's
equation
didn't look like maxwell's equations as
they should too
so
so then i was sent to dublin
to h201 study in dublin
and i've been showing you the famous art
and showing one of the founders of
calling me kelly's
the shooting equation i was director of
the institute
so i went there and i went up and they
always
interviewed by showing a sad on his bed
with a little cap on his head
and a small bedroom
and he had my papers
which uh i had sent a height today
and uh science i sent it to him no
i had copies and i
had just given them to bohr and
at the department of
i was invited to in london and so on
people
and they sent it to schulich so then
he got angry and said why are you using
albert's
methods to do this theory because
schroeding was working on the
non-symmetric
theory he published several papers i was
in the
in the um
proceeding the royal irish academy
which published papers on greek
philosophy and all sorts of issues
and um there was a dispute between
einstein and
schweininger it turned out because
schweringer was interviewed by
newspapers
because of his uh publication of unified
field theory
and uh claimed that he'd solved the
problem
uh but wasn't happy about this because
he had solved the problem
so they had this personal dispute and
paulie had to intervene
because they could it could rather
famous physicist uh nobel prize winner
and um
anyway so this was the atmosphere i was
interviewed
in and uh so charlie had his way of
deriving
the non-symmetric theory i'm einstein
had his way
doing it and so training was anxious i
wasn't using
heroin schrodinger's way okay why are
you not using my weight
i
and uh i had to be diplomatic
anyway so back to london
so the next thing is that schweiner sent
a letter
to the people
in london this department of scientific
research in london and uh
the latter argumentation must have been
something
because uh the next thing is i'm sent to
trendy college cambridge
to be interviewed by dennis sharma
who was a student of paul iraq
and he was a gone fellow of
trinity college and he was always
a lecturer at the time at cambridge
university
and so i was interviewed by
sharma in his rooms at trinity and
after about 20 minutes he said come with
me
so we walk across the trinity
great court and lawrence and when your
dawn can
walk on the lawns but i was with him i
couldn't eat him
and i otherwise had to walk on the
gravel path
and uh taken to the border's office the
trinity and
dennis said this gentleman john moffett
has to be
matriculated as a phd student at the
this is without an undergraduate degree
nor master so they looked into this
person he said
he doesn't have any degree it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter no okay so we're
meticulating him
and yes okay all right
so that so i was given the
supervisor uh professor
of supervisor fred hoyle
and uh i went to see him at st george
college
in his rooms and he said well you don't
have an undergraduate degree
no well maybe you should think about
taking the tripod exams
these are the famous exams antichrist
exams like cambridge
and something called the mathematics
tripos
first part and second part and so on
and uh well i
i was rather precocious and
so somewhat arrogant i should say as a
young man
i fell in like so i said well
uh uh professor ohio it's just
this is just gonna waste my time because
i know all this okay
so he he looked at me dubiously he
went through the tripods himself
he said in his biography carl's
biography
he had problems with that
getting through and it was brilliant of
course but
they were very hard exams and uh
so he's probably thought well if i
entered two of his voices
this person was
21 year old you know so i can understand
his
attitude so i decided that something
should be done about this
so i wrote three papers okay within two
or three months
and uh submitted to the proceeds at
cambridge philosophical society
and the first paper was very
mathematical it was a generalization of
romanian geometry
and the other two were my first modified
gravity theory and long papers
the paper on there i was trying to unify
gravity and electromagnetism in my own
way okay so i invented this
way not showing a no heinz this is a
different way of doing it
and so they accepted them
three papers so i mean
cambridge proceedings as an ancient
history i mean
famous mathematicians and my physicists
were published there
schrodinger published papers there and
calling me coy
so i went back to to fred hoyle
and uh i gave him the papers
when he sat and looked at them and he
said well
forget about the tripods exam just
continue with what
you're doing that was it
so i did my own research
i went had to go to um
california to do his steady state theory
and
work with fowler william fowler at the
caltech in pasadena
and uh visit other institutions so i had
to get another supervisor so i got
up to salam who was
at that time a lecturer at saint john's
college
where direct was and uh
i just did my own thing i attended two
courses
i never took any exams i didn't bother
with that
but i attended a couple of i attended
your ex course
twice because it was brilliant and i
just
caught him curious i was fascinated by
my quote encouraged myself
how was direct as a teacher as a
lecturer very good
very clear excellent
did he speak much he has a reputation he
started off with a loud voice
and uh
to make sure that he was being heard
and then even especially in the back of
the classroom
a lot of the students attended all the
graduate students
research students attended in physics
because they were famous it's based on
his book
on coinback guys and then his voice
would be
so more muted because he realized that
people were beginning to that the people
were able to understand his speech
anyway uh so
i continued my work on
general relativity i worked on the
equations of motion
and general relativity it's what's
called the icing for hoffman method
and i write in my unified theory this
was going to be my thesis
and then i switched to particle physics
because i was already well ahead
with uh my
gravity work but i started becoming
interested in particle physics and
quantum field theory
so i started going to record i feel
syrian
and uh by the way in the first year
as a student there are about six or
seven of us
in the maths department i've got what's
called bennett street
cambridge and um
we entered a room where we kind of could
meet
that big room and uh
so after a year we were told to give a
lecture we had seminars every thursday
and uh i had to give a seminar on my
work
which was some quantum field theory not
gravity
and uh i worked on the actual matrix of
quantum field theory
and what's called hagg's theorem
developed by us actually developed by
developed by
a german physicist called hagg
rudolph hogg and paulie worked on this
hack serum at the time of king part so
i gave this lecture and it was very
original work
and uh i used um
notation of fred freed friedman
um american
quarterfield theorist in new york
university
published a book so i direct and said to
me asked a question
he says what are those round brackets
i said this is what you call bras and
kits
the triangular brackets and he said well
that's
very interesting he was fascinated by
this
who invented this professor friedman
anyway
so so uh
three or three of them were failed
it was pretty brutal there was no
example we were just to give this
lecture an original physics research
and if you didn't make it you were out
he was sent down
from cambridge and so i was one of the
points that survived
so phd in 1958
uh during the course of my work
i met roy carr the current metric
he came in from new zealand to be a
trinity college where
we would became friends and so he said
what should i do i said well
i said what about physics you know
he was a brilliant mathematician i said
well do
gravity general relativity you don't
have to worry too much about the physics
at the moment
because generality was not that well
developed at this point
we're talking about 1956-57
so even after einstein died general
relativity wasn't
completely developed no so the general
relativity that we learned in university
is the fully articulated form that
einstein didn't even
put yeah it was being developed still
being developed and
so on at the time and mathematically
speaking and
there was not enough experimental data
you see
uh it was not that cosmology was an
infancy
during my work i read a paper by
einstein an infill
published in 1949 and uh
info was polish physicist more so
and uh
i found a mistake it was wrong i think
so i got all the right
gripe that i said have a look at this
i did the calculations and uh
he looked at he said yeah you're right
it's wrong
so we brought a paper together we
thought we should do something about
this
and because there was a famous paper
there was a famous
photograph of a albert einstein at the
front of the
in the front of the paper that this was
it was the canadian journal of
mathematics
to publish the paper and this photograph
was by kash
famous photographer called kash
and anyway so uh
we wrote up this paper and sent it to
physical review
it was it was uh reviewed by
peter bergman who was one of einstein's
assistants that needs to do it
at one point uh he was editor one of the
editors of
physical review and he wrote back saying
you can't we can't publish this paper
because it's uh best marks the
reputation of
famous physicist albert einstein
so i got upset about it
and uh i
i was kind of angry about that i i was
at the version of leading physics like i
can't deal with this you know
so because you have
responsibility for posterity younger
physicists who
can use this work so
i got my phd
they were not happy if i'm i put this i
started working on it to to collect it
okay
and wrote a paper and i put it into my
phd thesis
and my examiners were not entirely happy
with it
and uh but there wasn't anything they
could do about it
so uh
i then uh eventually i got my phd
without an undergraduate degree by the
way i was
i think the one at that time maybe still
the only student at trinity to get a phd
without an undergraduate degree
i think in theoretical physics anyway
i know maybe that's still true i don't
but um um so it's
fairly unique these examples weren't
happy about that either of course
because they had this guinea pig okay
so to speak who was going through this
system in cambridge
it is impossible to do this okay well
i did it so
uh then i got a fellowship
from the same department in dutch of
scientific industrial research
who originally called me to to england
uh to a two-year fellowship that's why i
went to imperial college
in the meantime after salaam was made
professor at empire college london
and uh here i was i was pulling an
office need to his office
i was his first postdoctoral fellow
and started working in particle physics
and field theory
and but i was worrying about
getting a job at this point i was
married
to my dad and uh
um so i got ahold of i
i caught his father john wheeler prince
and he suggested apply for childhood
an institute for research in baltimore
maryland
which i did they offered me a job so i
went there in 1959
and uh was at this institute
i was a senior researcher there i was
doing particle physics and field theory
they also had a math department and uh
solomon lynch lipschitz was the director
of the mass the famous
most institute there and
then uh quickly uh
i published papers in particle physics
um published a lot of papers
rapidly at physics particle physics
then i was offered a java university of
toronto
as associate professor already
with the promise of being made full
professor within
a couple of years which again is very
unusual
and uh i got a job there
i had to do teaching full-time teaching
so i started teaching undergraduate
courses
and i never i'd never attended
undergraduate courses
but i did okay and
graduate courses and so on so
[Music]
that's it
do you know who ryan keating is he's an
experimental physicist
uh yeah yeah i read his book oh how to
lose nobel prize
quite an amusing entertaining book